hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video were back on monster hunter world
again and today were gonna be tackling
another one of the solo guides and in
specific we're gonna be talking about
bracket Dios the green fisted boxer and
his main claim to fame of being the
slime fish or at least in monster honor
world is now considered blast but we'll
get into that a little bit later but
yeah I like to be if you do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new and let's get
started so bracket deals like I said his
main claim to fame was the slime fish
back in the day he used to have slime
damage but since slime doesn't exist in
monster on a world they changed it to
blasters that is what I've been told he
is weakest to ice and water and all
ailments are to start and water is I
believe also too started in Isis 3 so
that would be his advice and he's
resistant to fire so deftly try to stick
away from that his enraged mode is very
clearly visible when his hands are
yellow just a little bit of information
just in case you need to be having
agitator or something like that you'll
know when he's in rage because his fists
will be yellow and it's very apparent
for some Mantle's I recommend evasion
temporal Rocksteady all that good [ __ ]
they're all gonna be working their
health and affinity booster will also be
helpful as well any combination whatever
you choose to use is also going to be
nice some of the I like to state these
sometimes because some characters you
know like engine happening on him being
a monster with fire obviously you might
want to have the fireproof mantle on so
you have to kind of conform to what he
does but for Bracken DLC I kind of
realized that you can use any assortment
of Mantle's or a boosters that you want
you can kind of do whatever you feel
like as none of these really are going
to affect you for one histah lime does
hurt a lot and can apply the blast
blight effect but only three times you
can get rid of it but for the slime be
wary of where it is it starts to go
green then yellow to orange to red and
then bright red and then explode so
remember where they are in trying to
have to get caught because if you do get
caught in it you will have this little
slight animation and then it might also
blow up and also give Braca deal so free
hit on you he can do this slime move by
slamming once charging you pounding the
ground and pretty much anything that he
does
90 percent of the time there's going to
be some slime following him so
definitely be aware even when he's
trying to run away from you to go to the
next area
I've seen some slime that he leaves away
and I've almost been hit by it so
definitely be watching out for that he
would try to track you with the charge
but sometimes he misses and run runs
right into the wall so no worries there
the charge is a pretty simple move if he
gets a little bit too close for comfort
just dive and let the iframes do the
work
Braca deals can also leave
towards you as water close the gap once
again dodge if you're a little bit too
nervous or simple dodge depending on
your distance it should be fairly easy
from there the area in the elders recess
at least for the story mode is pretty
much perfect for the potential turf wars
that happened the icicles on the ceiling
in the one ice room the lava fountain
that erupts into the side room with fire
everywhere so plenty additional ways to
get some damage on him if you don't want
to keep fighting him constantly and you
also want to knock him out and get that
free damage it's really helpful that's
what I love the elders recess he also
likes to do a small tail swipe but
nothing crazy but he does hit twice the
clutch claw can also come in very easily
for some nice spots to soften up his
body a little bit get some extra bait
damage he also loves to slam his head on
the ground when nearby for an AoE
explosion which will do loads more
damage if you have the blast blade on so
definitely get away from that as well as
he likes to use a little bit of those
blasts explosives as a straight line so
also very simple to dodge just go left
or right just don't dodge forward or
backward you can of course do the dive
and get those iframes but what's the
point you might as well just dodge to
the side that's just a waste of time
when enraged like I said he turns yellow
but he also charges a lot more often
hits harder and faster it likes to swing
a lot more I noticed doesn't do a lot of
the slower moves that he does he likes
to be really up in the face cuz he's
pissed off at you and he especially
likes to do a supernova move which I've
only seen him do in the enraged state so
this possibly could be just the enrage
type move set it's a supernova move with
the explosion when it arranged
it's a supernova type move kind of
similar to Teo straw or loon Astra but
just a tad bit different where it
explodes going outwards so when he
pounds the ground the slime starts from
closer to him and then goes towards you
so the slime that originally appears
first will go on that timer and will
blow up first so if you are caught in
the back and it's kind of right on top
of you just dive out of the way and
you'll be ok with the iframes or just
run away possibly depending on the
distance you're at really shouldn't be
that too hard but of course if you're up
in his face for the melee weapon this
could be some trouble so there's really
no problem which is diving lit and the
iframes do the work here as always let
me know in the comments below if you
know something I didn't stay in the
video or I happen to get some
information wrong and I will definitely
believe that in the comments and I will
leave a pin comment of all your
information down there so that it's all
comprised
so that people don't have to go through
the 10
hundreds of comments that come up and
just to try to find a little bit of info
it'll all be displayed in the ping
comment down below yeah thank you guys
for watching the video hopefully guys
this is helping you throughout these
solo guises I'm making as once again is
like eventually start getting through a
lot more of the monsters I'll be
covering more their stuff and eventually
we'll be getting to all the monsters as
you know Val kana at the very end which
already did a guide on her Nami Ella
towards the ending which we already know
that monster existing I just don't know
when she's coming out as well as the a
ton of other monsters that are releasing
a nice burn that I haven't even gotten
to yet yeah just look out on the channel
for that so we're gonna be trying to
cover majority of them there's a lot of
subspecies in the game which I might
after I finish the story mode go back to
what a later date cuz some of them are a
bit easier like the coral Pooky Pooky
but like ebony odo grana nat acidic
Glavine asar giving me a little bit of
trouble so I might hold off on those
till later I might upload them soon I'll
have to figure out for myself yeah but
that guys like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I covered the
solo guides and Monster Hunter world as
usual just to just in case somebody is
trying to farm a specific monster but
doesn't really remember all the
statistics or is just trying to pass
through the story mode to get to that
ending and seeing kind of what the story
of ice-born is if it did help you leave
a like so I know I did some good for you
and hopefully made your day a little bit
easier as I said like if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new and take care
guys have a great rest your day and visa
[Music]